the dirt roads wind up this mountain of
refuse made of four and a half million
tons of garbage trucks come from all
corners of Delhi bringing a further
eight thousand tons of waste per day
that garbage is the only source of
income for around five hundred waste
collectors they are a marginalized group
the gossiper landfill and the immense
problems at poses are something most of
Indian society does not want to know
about activists vermland ajar wants to
help the people who are in existence
here it's the children in particular
whose plight concerns him from the yard
at the landfill that's where the trucks
are getting dumped if you see there's a
huge dumping and as soon as that dumping
takes place boys run after that to
collect some some garbage these are tiny
kids and you know most of them are ten
twelve fourteen year olds many of them
are younger than that they're all waste
collectors they're all rat pickles who
try to really make a living out of waste
okay
chewing tobacco helps stave off hunger
and the terrible stench many of the
children are orphans their friends are
the only family they have on a good day
they might earn two euros from the
plastic bottles metal parts and even
human hair they collect
it's enough to survive but not to escape
the filth of the refuse dump
the waste pickers of gauzy pools serve
an important function they salvaged
recyclable material that would otherwise
be lost forever there's hardly any
recycling that is done by the government
in the sense if there's any recycling
that is only done by the RAC because if
you see this they segregate the garbage
they segregate things and sell it in the
informal market in a way there's nothing
in terms of this management other than
transportation these rickety trucks that
you see that is what is the government
effort and that's it
india's refuse problem has reached
alarming proportions one of the harps of
informal electronic waste resampling is
found in the north of delhi in alleys
and backyards here men and children take
apart televisions and computers
processors and hard drives
in Delhi alone some 30,000 people are
involved in informal e-waste recycling
the material used to come from all over
the world now most of it is the refuse
of India's growing middle class
the system is incredibly efficient but
there are no controls in place here when
it comes to the environmental and human
cost
this is where the German Agency for
International Cooperation comes in its
team wants to help use the potential of
the informal sector while meeting
environmental and health and safety
standards cycling system as a whole
there are different elements of it so
there's one element which is
pre-processing which is basically about
dismantling the not segregating the
materials and in that process
India's incredibly efficient it's much
more efficient than any other country in
the world including Germany and other
countries in the EU however when you
come to the next step of recovering
materials from the dismantled material
that's where you go wrong in India the
agency has set up new recycling
facilities to combat the problem the
idea is to use the knowledge of the
informal waste collectors as a way of
improving the recycling process harm to
human health or the environment is
minimized circuit boards contain small
amounts of gold and other precious
metals as well as valuable copper in
addition to running a profitable
operation the agency also wants to
create new prospects for the people
working in the informal sector and
traditionally also it's mean the
occupation of the marginalised and that
is one of the major drivers for them to
formalise so when we go and talk to them
and when we say ok you will be a part of
the mainstream they actually like that
part if India is to solve its growing
refuse problem society will also have to
reassess its view of the waste pickers
or kabadi mullahs as the scrap dealers
are often called
right next to the landfill they sought
the items they've salvaged before
selling them elsewhere in bulk
this unregulated community of e-waste
collectors are taking care of a task
that should be the responsibility of
local authorities if it weren't for
their hard work
entire cities in India would be
suffocating in garbage it's so
unfortunate that we have these poor
people who are doing this but imagine if
they were not doing it who would be
taking care of our environment so I
consider these rag pickers as the great
green warriors who don't get recognition
for their environmental work they are
really doing a big service to the
environment and our planet
a couple of years ago the melendi saw
the huge potential involved he was
determined to find a way of literally
revaluing the material a concept he
calls upcycling this is the philosophy
behind the green the gap project turning
trash into fashion and opening up new
opportunities for the waste collectives
from the landfill when the rack Pickers
collect also from neighborhoods when the
rack because collect a lot of this they
bring it here and we buy it from them so
these are different kinds of ships
packet that you see also here this side
we have some more rubber so you know
it's kept in drums in this entire thing
what you see is these juices juice boxes
tetrapack cartons they're again made
into wallets and what men's wallets
ladies wallets and bad green the GOP's
flagship store is located in the upscale
house cars area of Delhi and does a
brisk business there
idiot selfish goods to customers
worldwide it's a creative way of making
India's growing consumer society more
aware of recycling